welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for our presentation titled practical
advice for working with regulators it's
my pleasure to introduce you to dr fine
glass
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box our speaker will
address your questions following at the
end of the presentation
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
please join me in welcoming dr fine
glass i will now turn the presentation
over to her dr fine glass
good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you are in the world
i'm really excited to be with you today
today we're going to talk about some
practical advice on working with
regulators i've spent the last 20 years
in and out of government and
really
feel that the best way to make sure you
understand
where your product is in a pipeline how
to bring it to market
and how to bring it to market
effectively you really have to
understand the regulatory system within
which you're working and you really have
to understand how to approach the
regulators
so we'll go through that today
and we'll wrap up with a few tips and
tricks that i have for you and and have
uh
learned over the years
so
many of you who
have met me before know that i'm a
public health physician by training and
so this is my one piece around please
make sure if you are offered a
vaccination that you have a way to get
it
i will tell you that one of the
silver linings of being in a pandemic is
rolling up your sleeves and really being
able to bring products to market that
make a difference so
my my takeaway for you already for today
is know how to work with your regulators
and the key to success in a regulated
market and gaining access to that market
is bring something useful to that market
and again
don't give away your shot if it's
offered please do get vaccinated
so as i mentioned i'm a public health
physician by training i've spent years
in and out of government and running
large global organizations i'm the chief
medical officer at danaher diagnostics
and life sciences and also run market
access and reimbursement and policy for
the company with that in mind as we move
forward through the talk today i want to
remind you of what the agenda will be
so the first part is why
it's really important to interact with
your regulator or regulating body
depending on where you are in the
country
because it allows you to move your
products forward efficiently
and
understanding
consistently what it takes to move
forward in that market
and again no matter what country you're
seeking approval in it is really
important to understand the differences
in the regulatory pathway
i'm also going to talk about how so the
basic framework for regulation of
diagnostic tests
it differs depending on what country or
region you're in i'm going to highlight
the us and the eu today but please note
that if you're in asia pac or lattam or
other areas of the world there are
always difference in differences in how
you approach your regulators and frankly
what those regulatory pathways are
and depending on where you are trying to
bring a product to market in you need to
make sure you understand those
and then the when so we need to protect
public health now as we look at what's
needed around the diagnostic space and
how to bring diagnostics to market
understanding that all of what we do
serves public health is an important
grounding piece for me it's a really
important piece again as a public health
physician to understand that at the end
of the day the products that
many of us are producing
the end user is
a patient
a clinician some combination of the two
and at the end of the day we want to
make the world a better place
for people that are seeking to manage
their health
so the first piece of advice is please
seek help early it's really important
that you build those strong working
relationships with regulators and you
really need to understand what the
successful outcome is that you're trying
to achieve and understanding
how to get there
in order to get there you have to
understand what the regulators need what
helps them make the decisions
there is
no more important piece
than a very well written concise
reasonably argued
regulatory submission
there's no substitute for that
in addition you want to make sure you're
meeting with regulators to seek their
early feedback in the u.s dealing with
fda we have something known as
pre-submission
in all
all the different geos of the world
there are different ways to meet with
your regulator early on in your process
so that you can get that needed feedback
so that you can make sure
that you're filing what needs to be
filed for a successful application so
that you can move to market
in as short a period of time as possible
you want to always utilize that feedback
to fine-tune the development of your
strategy
so often when we're working with either
notified bodies or fda we're seeking
input into
the submission that we are planning on
putting in we want to know
based on the clinical trial attributes
we're putting in here does this make
sense
regulating body does this does this have
the attributes you need we're following
your guidance however are we missing
something is there something that can
enhance this is there something
that
uh you you can help us understand
so that we prepare a better submission
for you
those are very common conversations and
you should not shy away from those
conversations
when you utilize that feedback to
fine-tune that strategy you then want to
follow those timelines provided by the
regulator and respond appropriately
key here is you need to make sure you're
staffed appropriately to do so when
you're in the middle of submitting
a submission
and
you have a
complicated product it's probably going
to take more staff to complete that
submission than if you have
a run-of-the-mill sort of simple
product that you're bringing to market
and
you need to take a really close look at
what your requirements are going to be
to understand how you need to staff up
to meet the needs of the regulators
this allows you as a manufacturer to
understand well
you know do i if i want to come to
market it you know
next year what's it going to take to get
there how might i go quicker or
strategically if i need to slow down how
do i plan for that
you're going to need staff that help
with this
if you don't have staff internally you
need to reach out to external
contractors to help you develop that
strategy but the key here is make sure
up front that you know how you're going
to interact with those regulators and
make sure that you're staffed with
people that know how to do that whether
internally or externally
and remember those timelines
are literally set in stone so if you
want to
respond as quickly as you can to the
regulators you've got to know what their
expected timelines are
so here's a
basic
piece of background on the us and the eu
and the key is
each of the
regulating bodies for the fda in the
united states or notified bodies in the
eu
play a critical role in protecting the
public's health
the united states fda
looks at safety and effectiveness
and they decide is that test meeting um
those specifications is the quality of
the design and manufacture of the
diagnostic test appropriate to move
forward
in a safe and effective manner that's
what fda looks like
in addition in the
in the us while fda looks at safety and
and
effectiveness
medicare
when it comes to diagnostics
looks at the quality of the clinical
laboratories in the clinical testing
process
so there's there's two pieces in the u.s
if you're bringing a diagnostic to
market
one is fda which deals with the safety
and effectiveness and
for shorthand what we would say the
approval of that product but cms also
then regulates the quality of the
clinical laboratory so this is what we
talked about when we say clia or clia
waived so you need to understand that if
you're bringing a diagnostic to the us
market you need to make sure that you
understand the fda process and the cms
process
flipping over to the eu
all diagnostic tests are required to
undergo a conformity assessment
and that's where the manufacturer
demonstrates that the product complies
with the requirements set
out in the application
in the applicable rather legislation
and your notified body
really assesses the conformity of those
products
so at the end of the process in the eu
you are given a ce mark and that
demonstrates that you have
satisfied the applicable eu requirements
so this is just the u.s and the eu there
are many other geos i know you're all
working in
but these are two that i find are very
useful for people wanting to learn more
about diagnostics because they're there
where there are very
um
there are slight differences in how each
of those geos move those diagnostics
forward
so focusing first on notified bodies in
ibdr
i would be remiss if i didn't say that
in europe
the ibd regulations that are coming into
play are really the biggest change in
the ibd space that we've seen in the
last
decade or more
and the key here is it relies on
notified bodies
for those not familiar a notified body
is
really that key pillar in the medical
technology regulatory system in in the
eu they really provide the the review
in consultation with the manufacturer on
making sure that they meet
the
um requirements
as you will see on the right slide right
side of this slide
prior to the ibdr regulations going into
place
about 20 of um
ce mark
met the requirements based on working
with a notified body and having a
conformity assessment
but the other 80 percent you didn't need
the notified body conformity assessment
the shift that is happening now and goes
finally into place in may of 2022
is that 80
will be certified with notified body
conformity assessment so if you can see
we've gone from 20
percent
of the ibd on the market in europe
needing notified body conformity
assessment to 80
now needing certification with notified
body conformity assessment
this is a big lift this is a big change
for those of you newer to the
ivd space
this has been a significant lift for any
manufacturer in this space working in
europe
so i've added this topic in here just as
a reminder to those of you that are
deep in this space but also those of you
that are newer to this space that as you
move towards diagnostics in the eu there
are some very significant very
significant regulatory changes
this is just a quick slide on the
timeline so again
many of you know this
enforcement for ivdr begins may 26 2022
and then there will be a period of time
before
the previous what were referred to as
ivdd certificates expire
and then there's a period of time before
those devices have to be off the eu
market so again 2022
is when that enforcement begins for ibdr
and then by
um
late 2024 early 2025 or when those
those uh diagnostics that do not meet
the new requirements must
begin to be removed from the market
so when you look at the new regulation
of diagnostics in europe the big key
here is that
if you're bringing an ibd
to the european market there's just a
different
level of
restriction now
and
you need to make sure that you're
familiar with these dates and
understanding that once fully
implemented
ibd compliance rules ensure almost all
of the ibds entering the european market
will be subject to that notified body
review remember you saw previously 20
now 80
that's how you'll move to ce mark
i want to switch for a minute and look
at the us
so many have asked about emergency use
authorization and public health
emergencies and what that means
as we're moving diagnostics forward so
in the united states we have emergency
use authorization or what we call eua
and
eua authority allows fda to help
strengthen the nation's public health
protections
there is a statute that allows this to
happen
and it allows the secretary of hhs to
declare an emergency use authorization
to be appropriate
to date when we look at the pandemic
that we're in there have been about 377
tests related to covet 19 that currently
have
eua
that does not include the numbers that
are in review right now with the fda
looking for eua
should you want more information
about what tests have been approved
under eua and in general more
information about testing i find that
the arizona state university testing
commons
run by maura asthma tends to be very
helpful i've put the link down here and
referenced for you so you can look at
that site but they have been pulling
data globally
and focusing on what tests are coming
through again specific to coven 19.
so
eua
again if you follow this stepwise from
step one to step six
we start with confirming that there's a
public health emergency
then once you have confirmed there's a
public health emergency there is a
formal declaration of that emergency
again these steps are important in the
us because it's how we're able to move
to eua
once you have that declaration of
emergency as you know you can start
developing your product and filing for
eua
and so that pre-eua submission is really
important because it's a piece
in the in the framework where you can
actually have that pre-meeting so that's
the pre-meeting that i talked about
in a normal frame it's a pre-submission
with a pre-eua submission meeting you
can actually talk about that product
with the fda get feedback from them
understand what else they need for your
filing and then
rapidly move to a more complete
submission
step four is that submission of the eua
step five is that approval or rejection
of the eua and again you'll be having
communication with the fda through this
whole process at the appropriate
timeline
and then
step six is eua termination so at some
point in the u.s
we will be out of this public health
emergency
and once
the u.s government determines that we
are no longer in a public health
emergency
they
they terminate the emergency they end
the emergency
and then those emergency use
authorizations
go away
and so the key for those of you
interested in filing diagnostics in the
united states and interested in using
the eua pathway you need to understand
that at some point
that expires and you need to transition
your diagnostic
to the normal regulatory pathway
if
you are intending to keep that in in the
market after a pandemic end
so again just a reminder on eua eua is a
temporary
approval if you think of it that way it
is for a defined period of time that
period of time being while there is a
public health emergency that has been
declared by the us government
once that public health emergency is
over
there is a a period of time in the eu
start to
um they terminate so you
as someone bringing forward diagnostics
to the in the us if you're bringing it
under eua need to understand when that
termination happens and if you're
intending to keep it on market how you
would convert it
in the eu there's also a way to declare
public health emergency for those of you
there you you know this well
and
in the case of
an emergency relating to health and
safety the
eu commission and member states will
grant access to the eu market for
devices that
have not followed the normal conformity
assessment routes
that is what's going on now
it is a temporary authorization of a
diagnostic test again under this public
health emergency for a limited period of
time
to date
there are about 748 tests related to
cobit 19 that have a ce mark
again this information is from
the testing commons at arizona state
university
so as i mentioned when i was talking
about eua what happens after this
remember
in any geo that you're in if you're
filing during
a public health emergency and there is
an expedited
approval process that you went through
eua or other you really need to make
sure you understand the regulatory
process to convert from that emergency
use
to what is the normal regulatory process
there's a lot of time that is involved
with this there are
generally more data that need to be
collected
and
you need to make sure that you're
preparing for that
so right now for many of us that have
filed
diagnostic tests under eua or other
public health emergency provisions in
other gos
many of us have to think about well if
we're going to keep this product on
market what are we going to do next so
again conversations with your regulating
authority
understanding how that process works are
essential for you being able to move
forward in that market
so protecting public health
happens when we bring needed tests to
market
so you've heard me talk a bit about
being in pandemic and the emergency use
authorization or other emergency use
processes you can go through to bring a
test to market but the key here when
responding to public health emergency in
this case a pandemic is you really need
to think globally
and you also then need to act locally
first
and the key here is you then need to
share those best practices as we try to
contain and eliminate the disease or
react to that
so whether in this case it's covid which
we are very all very deeply involved in
all of us are wrestling with but think
prior to cobit think about ebola
there were emergency authorization
provisions around ebola as well
and the key there was
we're responding to an outbreak we want
to make sure we can get the needed tests
there
and then we need to figure out
are the tests that are needed
in one region the same as in another
so again sharing those best practices in
order to contain
and eliminate disease is really
important and understanding how you're
going to protect public health is also
important so all of you that are
bringing diagnostics to market or all of
you that are trying to figure out how
best to leverage those diagnostics there
is going to be a component of what you
do that is very local
it is important to understand the needs
of each individual country
and that current public health framework
and then link those responses
and the key again there is you're going
to have different requirements in
different countries from a regulatory
pathway you already know that we've been
through that earlier in these slides
but the key also is
where you can leverage the same
technology globally it's a lot easier to
distribute your product but in some
cases there are going to be different
requirements or different disease
patterns that you have to meet
potentially with different tests so
understanding that up front
understanding what the public health
frameworks are within which you're going
to work and understanding how to match
your diagnostic that you're interested
in
to what that framework is will be
essential for your campaign forward
so a couple of questions
that that i always tell people to ask
for when bringing a product to market
especially in a public health emergency
number one who's doing the financing so
how are these tests paid for how are
these tests developed is there are there
any government funds to help develop
those tests these are important
we're in a pandemic there's been a lot
of funding around test development and
test deployment same with vaccine
development vaccine deployment
in a non-pandemic time when there is a
serious outbreak like take ebola
there is an important question of how is
that financing working and how does that
impact the regulatory or payment pathway
you're moving forward in in addition
what resources are available to
diagnostic manufacturers to ramp up
development quickly again where in
covert there's been more resources
available than i think any of us have
ever seen in the past but when you think
about outbreaks again using ebola as an
example
what resources are available both
regulatory advising resources meaning
are the regulators coming to the
diagnostic community and having
open forum to discuss the regulatory
pathways forward for this specific
disease type to discuss the the
confusion around any communication with
the regulatory pathway and to clarify
that regulatory pathway so understanding
those resources is important and then
finally how are those tests being paid
for again how development is financed is
one thing but then also depending on
what geo you're in understanding how
those tests are paid for is very
important as you're developing a
diagnostic test for the market
both within a pandemic and when you're
not an appendix
so other factors that i think are
important to consider in and out of
pandemic are
diversity and diversifying
so different populations responded
differently to coban 19. so if you take
that as your example
different populations
fared worse if they got coveted than
others different populations had testing
available to them
and so understanding the different
testing modalities and solutions needed
depending on what geo you're in are
important but even within a geo
you may have underrepresented
communities whether impoverished
communities underrepresented minority
communities people that bottom line do
not have access
to the products that you're producing
and you need to ask yourself the
question why is it
a system
issue meaning you've developed the
product but you can't get it to all the
people that need it well how do you fix
that so we don't end up with the haves
and the have-nots how do we
decide as manufacturers to meet those
needs of a diverse population
and how do we make sure that our
products are getting
to where they are needed everywhere
regardless
of those obstacles and
barriers in addition
when i talk about diversify i also mean
what are the diseases that you're
looking at to develop diagnostics around
you know post pandemic there is a need
for tests in a variety of spaces
especially in rare diseases and for
distinct groups
so sometimes there are differences
by
what your gender is by what your race is
to how you'll respond to
a disease process
some of it is related to
whether
you're a a group that is in the majority
or the minority other times it's related
to it just simply is a rare disease
and so as you're thinking about meeting
the needs of a very diverse community
where is your focus
on diseases that may have smaller
numbers of people but still people that
are in need of your tests
how do you think about how you're going
to develop your future diagnostics to
meet those needs
in addition
having diverse populations in your
clinical trials is essential we have
seen many efforts around the globe to
diversify clinical trials and i think
it's really important especially in the
time that we're in
in addition to diverse populations and
clinical trials
you really on need to look at real world
evidence development
so
we are
we are very used to randomized
controlled trials and understanding how
those are tightly controlled and how to
bring products to market using a very
well done randomized control trial
but what we're also seeing the market
move to and the regulators accepting
more is the notion that
that randomized control trial is really
important
but
how might we leverage real-world
evidence to move things forward
where we may not have an rct ready
and so understanding that there's a
combination of randomized control trial
and real-world evidence playing together
and that regulators are looking at both
is an important concept
in the us
there's a few different places we're
seeing this
pcori
which is one of the groups that's
looking at patient-centered outcomes is
looking at how you can leverage
real-world evidence
you have the medical device and
innovation consortium looking at
how do we put a framework around real
world evidence so that
regulators globally might be able to use
it
in a fashion that helps move products
forward in the market
and all the other geos have something
around real world evidence and the key
here is
know which geo you're in know which
regulators are looking at real world
evidence and be prepared for that coming
if you're not already there
finally when i look at personalized
medicine i look at it to say you know
how does this provide an understanding
of the community disease risk
so
if you take covid for example when we
were doing covet tests we saw
different distribution of the people
that were getting coveted in a city
in a state in a country in a region
and we saw some distinct patterns
that
pointed to
a
really a
a difference in who had access to
testing and then a difference in what
that outcome was so again looking at the
social determinants of health and
looking to limit disparities is
important and i think personalized
medicine plays a big role in that so for
those of you
listening who are in the diagnostic
space that are very focused on
personalized medicine i think it's a
really important place to be
finally on this it's really also about
how do we prepare for the next pandemic
better yet how do we prevent it and i
think diagnostic tests play a big role
in that
so some key takeaways you need to know
your regulators you need to know what
pathways are you need to know
how you can interact with them
appropriately
and if you don't know these things or
you're not staffed up
adequately to meet those needs you
really need to find external help
you need to be interacting with those
regulators before there's a critical
issue or an emergency that communication
is is key and understanding how you
access them is important there's
different groups
that have
very
good advice around this there's rats in
the u.s does a good job of this
as well as the trade associations here
and in europe
finally as you heard me say when i
opened vaccines will help us end covid19
please get vaccinated when you have a
chance wherever you are in the world
public health plays a key
role in keeping the world safe
diagnostics play a key role
in public health
all of you working in the diagnostic
space or thinking about working in the
diagnostic space or working adjacent to
the diagnostic space
have
an
a moment where you can say
you know what i'm going to make a
difference here i'm going to look at my
diagnostics that i'm developing i'm
going to look to see how this helps with
public health and at the end of the day
you're going to help build a society you
want to live in by keeping public health
at the forefront
so again
if you have a vaccine offered to you
please get the shot
until then if you're in an area where
there is not
enough
vaccine offered please stay safe keep
that mask on wash your hands
be kind and again thank you for your
time i appreciate your attention and
happy to answer any questions
thank you dr fine glass for that
outstanding presentation we will now
move into the live q a portion of the
presentation as a reminder please submit
your questions via the q a box
dr fine glass our first question is how
sophisticated do my questions have to be
when speaking to regulators
the questions do not need to be
complicated or technical
it's really important to establish that
strong foundational relationship with
the regulating agency you're working
with so the key there is really you just
want to be clear in your communication
that communication can be done by email
or phone or in-person meetings and they
don't have to be complicated it can be a
simple question that you really need
answered and they're happy to answer
awesome thank you for that insight there
now our second question is
i don't have a regulatory affairs team
so how do i submit an application for my
diagnostic test to be reviewed by a
regulatory agency
so you want to make sure that you seek
help early
if you know that you don't have staff or
experience in filing then you want to
look for
a regulatory affairs consultant
at the beginning of that project
and you need to build in that time
there are several consultants globally
that have experience going through all
the different regulatory processes
and they are always willing to help in
addition you can attend conferences
where companies discuss their
experiences seeking approval in the
market that you're interested in and
finally you can always look at the trade
associations around the
groups
of products that you're trying to bring
forward they off there's that's a place
where you can engage with
peer groups um have discussions that are
transparent about regulatory processes
and really learn and many of the trade
associations do
in person or or web training on
particular pro processes especially how
to file
an application for regulatory approval
in whatever market you might be in
thank you dr fine glass and
unfortunately due to time crunch this
will be our last question but thank you
to the audience for submitting all your
great questions
um and that question is how long does
the regulatory review process take
the regulatory approval process varies
depending on what market you're in
each
each market
each regulator has a list of
expectations that they make available
they're very transparent about how long
something should take
they're also getting more transparent
about
when that that stopwatch
stops meaning what can put your
application on hold so because each geo
has a different process and because
those timelines vary understanding what
those timelines are up front is really
important so that you can ensure the
process goes as smoothly as possible and
that's why knowing early
having companies investing and getting
the right help
to ensure that the process goes as
smoothly as possible given the very
tight timelines is an important first
step
thank you so much dr fine glass for your
wonderful insight here and a fantastic
presentation again today
um unfortunately we're out of time but
don't worry any questions that were
submitted and not answered today by our
speaker will be addressed via email
thank you again dr fine glass and thank
you to the audience for your outstanding
questions this presentation will be
available for on-demand viewing for 12
months please remember to share it with
colleagues who might be interested in
today's topic and don't miss out on the
other presentations on our agenda visit
the agenda tab in the auditorium for a
full listing
thank you again for your participation
and until next time goodbye
thank you